la question que j'ai envie de disposer
en vert c'est pas pourquoi c'est comment
et je sais ce que vous allez me dire
Robert vous êtes pas raciste et tout est
relatif Franck Ribéry pour lui il est
pas con donc vous voyez
et maintenant voici Mons stagiaire Tom
villa non
[Applaudissements]
des biens c'est quoi cette chanson ça
s'appelle il y en a des biens c'est une
chanson de Didier Super Thierry voilà
c'est un petit hommage pour Robert
Ménard les Arabes il y en a des biens
bah oui évidemment Thierry non je
parlais des électeurs du Front national
aussi doit y en avoir des biens
il faut les trouver mais bon bref en
tout cas très très beau plateau ce soir
Thierry Le radeau mange humoriste
comédienne alors pour ce qui vous
connaîtraient pas encore vous avez
commencé à jouer dans dans le métro
alors ça c'est pas grave c'est l'inverse
qui est plus relou puisqu'il est ce qui
est drôle c'est que bah quand tu es
humoriste bah c'est qu'en fonction des
villes où tu joues bah tu t'adaptes
forcément suivant la tournée des phrases
de ton spectacle par exemple je sais pas
au hasard à Béziers tu peux pas dire
est-ce qu'il y a des noirs des Arabes
dans la salle bah non il y en a pas
du Carlier rose ça fait plaisir de vous
voir Guy entre autres parce que vous
avez perdu du poids vous êtes en pleine
forme ça c'est cool il a perdu 100 kg
c'est quand même énorme
en disant en disant à 100 kg c'est
énorme 100 kg ça fait moi plus tout le
chiffre de Thierry plus trois cases de
champagne de Thierry c'est quand même
extraordinaire non alors Guy vous venez
ce soir pour nous parler d'un livre sur
Mathieu Valbuena qui contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser n'est pas un livre
de poche
vous avez écrit le livre qui veut tuer
Matthieu Valbuena et chez Laurent
Ruquier la semaine dernière vous avez
balancé que dans la vidéo de la sextape
c'était pas avec sa femme qui couchait
franchement Guy vous nous avez spoilé le
livre qui veut tuer Mathieu Valbuena
c'est sa femme évidemment
tout ça pour créer un buzz vos faut
faire un plus gros buzz par exemple
alors moi ce que je veux savoir il est
avec qui est-ce que je fais une blonde
un roux de Black un poney dites-nous Guy
mais tu le sais toi qui veux tuer
Mathieu Valbonne
m'a dit avant l'émission surtout te
laisse pas entraîner dans les questions
à la con je suis sûr qu'hardisson va te
demander avec qui il est c'est pas
Thierry qu'il demande c'est moi non non
mais non j'ai 50 2 4 5 ans
il est pas avec sa femme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non il y a eu le cas Black M aussi à
Verdun je suis d'accord avec vous voilà
moi non plus je voulais pas qui chante à
Verdun pas pour les mêmes raisons parce
que moi je pense que c'est franchement
de la merde franchement tiens ils
avaient entendu une alarme de Kangoo
sans déconner
vous savez qu'il a chanté à Béziers
c'est pas vrai je l'ai même autorisé
figure moi je n'aurais pas laissé
chanter à Béziers non plus alors
et vous avez dit aussi Robert j'assume
je ne veux pas que Béziers deviennent la
capitale du kebab c'est combien sont
rien à voir avec notre culture et je
suis d'accord aussi retour au bon vieux
jambon beurre c'est vrai pour ceux qui
mangent pas de jambon allez vous faire
[__] c'est vrai non pas les musulmans
les vegan c'est pire parce que ceux qui
dictent ta loi c'est pas Dieu c'est
aymeric Caron [__]
[Applaudissements]
la question que j'ai envie de lui poser
en vert c'est pas pourquoi c'est comment
et je sais ce que vous allez me dire
Robert vous n'êtes pas raciste et tout
est relatif Franck Ribéry pour lui il
est pas con donc vous voyez tout est
relatif voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est la relativité et puis voilà il y a
votre femme Emmanuel Duverger avec qui
vous dites former un couple très
fusionnel alors je pas briser votre
couple proverbe et fusionner le
fusionnel vous êtes marié avec elle et
pourtant elle a gardé son nom de jeune
fille donc même votre femme elle veut
pas porter votre nom Robert
[Applaudissements]
sur ce je trouve ça assez minable cette
dernière remarque pourquoi parce que je
trouve ça assez minable
en tout cas on va remonter l'ambiance
mais la messieurs je suis ici pour vous
poser les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
Laura demande alors Laura sur votre
ancien affiche de spectacle vous teniez
d'une main une sucette et de l'autre une
cigarette c'était pour prévenir le
public que pendant votre spectacle il
est interdit de fumer et de sucer
c'est ça l'icarlier Guy Franck Ribéry
avait porté plainte contre vous c'est
vrai qu'à cause des énormes fautes de
français la plainte avait été jugée il
receva par le tribunal
Robert Ménard il y a un truc que je
comprends pas chez vous vous êtes
catholique pratiquant à quel moment vous
avez loupé la phrase tu aimeras ton
prochain comme toi-même
[Applaudissements]
chérie j'y vais l'émission et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu